on the morning of the 1st of february
this year as myanmar was set to hold its
first session of parliament with the
newly elected government the army took
over a coup that some saw coming many
others didn't the army led by this man
min liang claimed fraud in recent
elections where nobel laureate aung sang
suchi's party swept to power
what followed was a bloody crackdown as
people rose up to protest their mandate
that was stolen right before their eyes
nighttime arrests on the 1st of february
democratic leaders locked up after
winning an election landslide
among those carted away nobel peace
prize winner and de facto political
leader anseong tsuchi
the junta's leader said the army
intervened after protests over alleged
election fraud he cited myanmar's 2008
constitution drafted by the army which
includes the power to suspend government
the army is always there for the
citizens
it always acts according to the law and
obeys the constitution of 2008
the army held the election so that all
the parties could have justice
immediately more protests swept the
country and in late february a general
strike
that didn't stop the military government
from arresting thousands of people
demonstrators were killed and some
protests became violent
since then the democracy movement has
suffered severe setbacks aung suchi was
charged with a variety of offenses
ranging from illegal use of
walkie-talkies to subversion
while some activists took up arms making
common cause in rural areas with
militant members of persecuted ethnic
groups like the koran who had long been
at war with the state dw spoke with
journalist amin thant earlier this year
about what that could mean
you know in many ways myanmar has been
in civil war for the last 70 or so years
i think what we're really seeing now is
uh the beginning of an all-out war in
which even the city centers uh are
affected and no one's really safe
whereas before you know people were safe
safer
especially if they were in urban areas
it's far from clear what the
international community can do the
military leadership has already survived
years of international sanctions and
pariah status on the world stage
with democratic leaders sidelined the
bloodshed seems almost certain to go on
to hong kong next where all democratic
protests continue to be constrained by
the national security law in the 18
months since it's been in force at least
150 people have been arrested including
well-known hong kongers like media
tycoon jimmy ly and student leader
joshua wong the crackdowns on freedoms
in their city has left many hong kongers
contemplating their future should they
stay or should they go to their protests
or do they move on with their lives as
best as they can
but in the midst of this gloom there has
been some welcome distraction a new boy
band that's redefining the cantonese pop
hong kong was famous for in the 80s
hundreds of people gather in a shopping
mall in hong kong
but this time they're not protesting
they're super fans of mirror the latest
boy band sensation
today three of mirror's 12 members are
making an appearance
after all the social upheaval in hong
kong it's a scene few could have
imagined
[Applause]
a lot of bad things happened in hong
kong in the past few years
many citizens were upset for a long time
but there was no emotional outlet
with mirror hong kong has become a
lively place again
pro-democracy protests a
freedom-shrinking national security law
and a clampdown on activists
all have dominated life in hong kong
and on top of the political turmoil is a
pandemic that still has no end in sight
for many mirror has become a welcome
escape
besides relief the group also offers
belief that the city's pop culture is
still thriving
[Music]
some say their music has marked a new
era of kanto pop
for a city that feels so beaten down
suddenly there's something people can
feel proud of again
it's a local group of course we need to
support them
they represent our spirit hong kongers
should support hong kongers
the band came out of a tv talent
competition
episode after episode dozens of
contestants gave their role to advance
to the next round
their persistence captured the hearts of
people of all ages
the boys worked hard for their dreams
and that's a mirror of our young people
today
many of them feel very disillusioned
i think the boy band can encourage young
people to endeavor again
for some the group holds up a mirror to
hong kongers
telling them they can still have dreams
in february india passed new rules that
essentially allow the government to
determine what people can and can't post
on social media it was a move some
activists likened to digital
authoritarianism this was evident just a
few months later in april as the country
buckled under the strain of a second
coveted wave as indians shared police
for help and information on availability
of beds oxygen and other medical
supplies the government asked twitter to
take down posts criticizing its response
tweets such as this one from member of
parliament from the opposition congress
party revanth reddy where he pointed to
the collapse of the healthcare system in
india due to the more than 200 000 cases
being recorded daily
minister in the state of west bengal
molloy gotok lamented that the
government had underplayed the
coronavirus situation in the country
west bengal was one of the indian states
worst affected by the rising cases
the government didn't officially say why
it had asked twitter to take down these
critical tweets but i asked one of
india's leading voices on the spread of
online misinformation and hate pratik
sinha if he thought the move was
justified
these were all very genuine criticism
with
no element of misinformation or hate and
does not at all
meet the standards of
twitter as a platform to
police these tweets
so is the government then using its
powers to block dissent on social media
absolutely all of these are tweets which
would be considered critical of the
government
and the government is uh forcing
platforms and unfortunately the
platforms are buckling as well uh but
the government is forcing platforms to
adhere to certain lines where you know
where descent is curved
but what about social media companies
themselves what part do they play in
keeping the democratic spirit alive a
very important one according to
philippines journalist maria reza she's
a joint winner of the 2021 nobel peace
prize
when i spoke to her in october after the
award was announced she explained why
social media companies in her country
are responsible for twisting facts and
how ultimately that is affecting
democracy here is a part of that
interview
i think that the rollback of democracy
globally and the tearing apart of the
shared reality has has been it's because
of tech it's because news organizations
lost our gatekeeping powers to
technology and technology
took the
revenues that we used to have you know
along with um
they took the powers but they abdicated
responsibility and i think this is is a
wake-up call and that's happening not
just for journalists with the nobel with
the nobel spotlight but also you are
seeing many more sophisticated
discussions about what exactly is wrong
that we're moving finally away from
content moderation
to
where we should be which is algorithmic
distribution algorithmic amplification
and how it has insidiously manipulated
human beings on the platform you have
you have been at facebook you have been
a part of many panels at facebook that
has looked at just things like these and
i mentioned facebook because it is very
popular in the in the philippines what
would you like to see happen with big
tech like facebook
i think the core of the problem is that
all the social media platforms treat
lies and facts identically they're data
points right and and the research has
now shown us that on social media
lies laced with anger and hate spread
faster and further than facts so you can
say that the world's largest delivery
platform of news
is actually biased against facts and
bias against journalism and as a result
of that fundamental choice that the tech
platforms have made we have
cheap armies on social media rolling
back democracy in 81 countries around
the world that is from oxford
university's computational propaganda
research project so
it's i think so here's the other thing
that dawned on me that the last time a
journalist was given this honor was in
1936
he wasn't able to go accept the honor in
person in oslo because he was
in a nazi concentration camp he
languished in a nazi concentration camp
and so i think that's the signal that
the nobel committee is telling us again
that we are kind of
at this existential moment where we
could lose our rights we could lose
democracy if we lose the facts